[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute messbar
guten abend und willkommen zum
nachrichtenüberblick an diesem mittwoch
die vom sport hat norbert lehmann ein
stück von mir und wir haben unter
anderem diese themen für sie
anspruch und wirklichkeit während
politiker beim impfen auf maximales
tempo drängen knutscht ist logistisch an
vielen ecken und enden
einer wird gewinnen im moment stellen
sich die drei bewerber um den
cdu-vorsitz gemeinsam den
parteimitgliedern die können sich dann
bis mitte januar entscheiden
säbelrasseln im osten russland nennt
seine manöver an der ukrainischen grenze
nur übungen trotzdem fordert die ukraine
von der nato beistand für den ernstfall
der präsident der vereinigung für
intensiv und notfallmedizin
schlägt heute erneut alarm die korona
lage werde wirklich zunehmend enger er
rechne bis weihnachten mit insgesamt
6000 corona intensivpatienten und zwar
unabhängig davon welche maßnahmen die
politik jetzt beschließt fester plan von
bund und ländern ist das impf tempo
massiv zu steigern
bis weihnachten sollen bis zu 30
millionen impfungen ermöglicht werden
das wären rund
1,25 millionen pro tag zum vergleich
gestern wurden 807 1000 dosen verimpft
und vielerorts bleibt der nachschub aus
sind 30 millionen bis weihnachten zu
schaffen luton leinhos hat nachgefragt
auch sachsen versucht zum jahresende
einen impf turbo zu zünden chemnitz
machte heute dieses frühere impfzentrum
wieder auf lange schlangen bei drei grad
außentemperatur
jetzt wurde mir gesagt dass nur ein
rechner geht dass sie auch nicht wissen
wie der ablauf ist ob sie überhaupt also
dass die ganzen rechner installieren
können wenn das nicht funktioniert
müssen alle leute nach hause gehen
solchen widrigkeiten trotzen und helfen
dass es vorangeht wollen sie in dieser
neuen praxis für arbeitsmedizin in mainz
600 impftermine bereits am heutigen
premieren tag
ich hatte noch eine andere stelle
angefragt da musste ich aber ziemlich
lange warten und hätte jetzt auch ersten
termin im ende dezember sieben tage die
woche von 9 bis 22 uhr mindestens 1200
booster impfung landtag sollten so
machbar sein sagt der chef
ich denke wir schaffen hier keine 30
millionen bis ende des jahres aber
wenn man entsprechende kapazität aufbaut
mit entsprechenden unterstützung von den
staatlichen stellen solche projekte wie
wir sie hier zum beispiel machen dann
auch entsprechend unterstützt kann ich
mir schon vorstellen dass wir das
hinbekommen
genügend impfstoff sei da so die
bundesregierung rund 50 millionen
impfdosen stünden bis ende dezember zur
verfügung
daraus lässt sich aussehen tatsächlich
dass die impfstoff dohlen dafür
ausreichend zur verfügung stehen jede
zusätzliche impfstelle zählt auch
apotheken die bereits grippe im stellen
sind wie diese hier in berlin wir haben
alle schulungen die qualifikation die
räumlichen voraussetzungen
und ja durchaus sehen wir uns da in der
lage und sind auch sehr motiviert ist
durchzuführen noch aber fehlt die nötige
ausnahmegenehmigung für corona impfungen
und in chemnitz musste heute die polizei
die unzufriedenen brennen
jetzt der blick auf die zahlen das
robert koch institut gemeldet
67.000
186 neuinfektionen binnen 24 stunden
302 mehr als vor einer woche und
446 todesfälle der höchste stand seit
neun monaten
die sieben tage incidents ist leicht
gesunken auf 400 42,9 allerdings sind
die werte nicht ganz aussagekräftig
viele gesundheitsämter sind am limit und
kommen mit den meldungen nicht mehr
hinterher um die vierte welle zu brechen
wollen bund und länder morgen
verschärfungen beschließen dem zdf liegt
jetzt der entsprechende entwurf forscher
gunter lambert in berlin was sind die
wichtigsten punkte
wenn es denn so kommt wie es in dem
entwurf drinsteht dann sieht es so aus
als würden bund und länder tatsächlich
sehr entschlossen auf bundesweit
einheitliche verschärfungen der
maßnahmen zu steuern dazu gehören dann
zum beispiel zweig für freizeit
einrichtungen wie kinos theaters und
restaurants und für den einzelhandel
ausnahme im einzelhandel während während
geschäfte für den täglichen bedarf also
das heißt dort zutritt nicht mehr für
ungeimpfte und auch mit in planung sind
strenge kontakt beschränkungen für
ungeimpfte danach dürfte bei ungeimpften
nur noch ein haushalt sich mit zwei
weiteren personen eines anderen
haushalts treffen ausgenommen sind
kinder bis 14 jahre und auch masken
pflicht an allen schulen für alle
klassenstufen steht jetzt in diesem text
drin also das ist schon relativ weit
gehen zum teil inzidenz unabhängig in
diesem entwurf was noch offen zu sein
scheint ist die frage bis zu welcher
größe großveranstaltungen zugelassen
werden und ab wann und ab welcher
inzidenz clubs und diskotheken
geschlossen werden sollen also da gibt
es sicherlich noch diskussionsbedarf und
man muss ja auch dazu sagen es ist
bisher noch ein entwurf da kann sich bis
morgen auch noch etwas bewegen
dankeschön schack und alaba nati nach
berlin
zur ohnehin angespannten lage kommt die
unsicherheit über omikron wie gefährlich
ist die neue corona variante ist sie
noch ansteckender wirken die impfungen
bei ihr in europa sind mittlerweile 59
infizierte erfasst die mehrheit davon
sind reiserückkehrer aus dem südlichen
afrika aber eben nicht alle was bislang
über omikron bekannt ist zeigt alexandra
vacano
omikron die neue corona variante seit
einer woche bekannt sorgt weltweit für
immer mehr fälle auch hierzulande wurde
sie bereits mehrfach nachgewiesen und
sie könnte schon stärker verbreitet sein
es ist nahezu sicher dass es mehr fälle
micr on in deutschland gibt als wir
aktuell wissen weil wir ja auch schon
fälle gesehen haben von leuten die nicht
nur reiserückkehrer aus südafrika waren
das heißt die haben sich angesteckt bei
anderen leuten forscher sind alarmiert
wegen der hohen zahl der mutationen auf
dem sogenannten spike protein der
omicron variante mit hilfe des proteins
kann das virus in menschliche zellen
eindringen und sich dort verstärkt
vermehren braucht es für omicron einen
neuen impfstoff ja ein angepasster
impfstoff sei nötig sagt stefan bratzel
ceo von moderner es werde aber monate
dauern nicht verrückt machen meint
dagegen ursachen von piontek der
vorliegende impfstoff könne auch gegen
die neue mutanten wirksam sein unsere
hoffnung ist dass ein gewisser
impfschutz vor allen dingen auch ein
impfschutz für schwere erkrankung bei
homefront
erhalten bleibt aber wir müssen davon
ausgehen dass zumindest der schutz vor
infektionen von symptomatischer
infektion reduziert ist eben weil
antikörper die durch die impfung oder
durch eine infektion mit einer anderen
variante hervorgerufen werden vermutlich
diese variante weniger gute kennen bei
bayern tag und moderner startet die
entwicklung eines neuen impfstoffs der
an die neue variante angepasst ist und
die korona tests schlagen sie auf
omikron an wir wissen dass die pcr tests
darauf anschlagen und es gibt auch schon
hinweise darauf dass einige von den
schnelltest sehr gut auf micro
anschlagen ob alle schnellstes auf
omikron anschlagen werden muss man auch
gucken aber die häufigsten dass es auch
schon gezeigt omikron die neue variante
sie macht sorgen doch das zentrale
problem ist weiterhin die delta variante
so hat die bundeswehr heute sächsische
intensivpatienten zu behandlungen nach
nordrhein-westfalen ausgeflogen
der korona impfstoff für 5 bis 11
jährige kann in der eu eine woche früher
ausgeliefert werden als geplant nämlich
ab dem 13 dezember das gab das
bundesgesundheitsministerium bekannt
deutschland soll in der ersten lieferung
24 millionen dosen von bayern texter
bekommen
unabhängig von corona wird sich der
pflegenotstand weiter verschärfen nach
einer neuen studie der barmer
krankenkasse steigt die zahl der
pflegebedürftigen bis
2030 auf rund sechs millionen menschen
eine million mehr als bisher angenommen
auf der anderen seite fehlen bis dahin
mehr als
180.000 pflegekräfte und schon jetzt ist
die lage dramatisch zeigt sibylle
bassler an einem beispiel aus bayern
das altenheim st franziskus im
bayerischen kolbermoor 100 menschen
werden hier betreut von pflegekräften
wie sandra häfner die aktuellen hohen
instanzen aber auch die neue
virusvariante belasten die stimmung ist
einfach sehr gedrückt und wir haben
wahnsinnige angst vor der vierten welle
die anspannung ist groß die folge allein
in ihrem bereich haben sich drei von
fünf pflegekräften krankgemeldet
mehrarbeit auf wenigen schultern auch
die heimbewohner spüren dies
so viel zeit für mich also ist alles
muss schnell doch es ist nicht nur der
stress und das ausgebranntsein des
personals was die lage in den heimen
zusätzlich verschärfen könnte so doris
schneider von der caritas sei die
angekündigte impfpflicht für das
pflegepersonal ihre sorge dass
tatsächlich von den bestehenden
mitarbeitenden der ein oder andere sagt
und so jetzt langt's mir endgültig
gesuche mir eine andere aufgabe margitta
leiminger arbeitet als hauswirtschafts
hilfe im heim die 41-jährige ist nicht
geimpft aus überzeugung für sie steht
fest
so wirklich hart kommt dass die sagen
sie müssen sich impfen dann würde ich
manchmal einen neuen weg suchen für mich
und kündigen für heimleiter jakob
hartmann eine unerträgliche situation
ich merke dass wir ständig versuchen den
ungeimpften
auf die füße zu treten und auf der
anderen seite nähert ab ich mich dabei
wie ich eine unendliche wut habt dass
die leute sich nicht hin zu lassen von
130 beschäftigten sind 15 ungeimpft
ersatz für sie zu finden auch im
ländlichen bereich nahezu chancenlos
wer wird neuer cdu chef drei männer
stehen zur auswahl seit einer stunde
stellen sie sich erstmals zur dritt den
fragen der basis klarer favorit ist nach
dem aktuellen zdf-politbarometer
friedrich merz mit 51 prozent zustimmung
unter unionsanhängern
gefolgt von norbert röttgen mit 23
prozent und schließlich helge braun mit
zehn prozent wie sich die drei gerade im
gespräch mit den mitgliedern schlagen
zeigt wenn die häscher
bislang sind sie immer nur solo
aufgetreten heute treffen sie sich zum
ziel die drei männer die chef der
angeschlagenen cdu werden wollen befragt
von 25 mitgliedern der partei und die
haben klare fragen
warum sind sie der beste kandidat
gewonnen wird die zeit gekommen sein
dass unsere partei eine doppelspitze hat
was bedeutet ihnen das c im parteinamen
und was bedeutet ihnen das
mitgliederschwund menschlicher umgang
miteinander afd im osten es geht ans
eingemachte
auch mit dieser frage die aufgabe des
neuen parteivorsitzenden wird sein ein
klares profil zu schaffen hinter dass
sich alle mitglieder stellen können aber
auch gemeinsam ein bild nach außen geben
können wie wollen sie das schaffen was
den umgangsstil miteinander betrifft ich
möchte dass das aufhört dass aus diesen
sitzungen live berichterstattung in der
bild -zeitung stattfindet ich werde in
den sitzungen darum bitten dass alle
ihre handys draußen lassen und dass wir
mal wieder vertraulich und
vertrauensvoll zusammenarbeiten
wir haben verschiedene wurzeln soziale
wurzeln liberale wurzeln und
konservativen wurzeln
das müssen wir als stärke begreifen so
wie früher für die cdu gleichzeitig
träger und und geißler gestanden haben
und irgendwie hatten alle das gefühl das
ist trotzdem eine starke cdu wer ist
denn der heiner geißler von heute also
personen die für unterschiedliche
inhalte gestanden haben und miteinander
gerungen haben ich glaube dass wir das
nicht mehr haben das ist ein fehler von
uns ab vierten dezember dürfen die cdu
mitglieder abstimmen
am 17 dezember gibt es das ergebnis
die spannungen zwischen der nato und
moskau nehmen weiter zu grund ist der
russische truppenaufmarsch nahe der
ukrainischen grenze die usa sagen es
gebe beweise für eine geplante invasion
russlands präsident putin dagegen wirft
dem westen aggressionen vor und verlangt
verlässliche
sicherheitsgarantien florian neumann
berichtet vom nato treffen in riga
im krieg der bilder liefert russland
heute neues material das land beginnt
sein nach eigenen angaben reguläres
winter manöver zum teil an der grenze
zur ukraine
dessen regierung fürchtet dass es nicht
bei der übung bleibt und so forderte in
klinische außenminister heute in riga zu
gast bei der nato politische wie
militärische unterstützung und den nato
beitritt seines landes
wenn die ukraine in schwierigkeiten
gerät gerät die gesamte ostflanke der
nato in schwierigkeiten ein
nato-beitritt der ukraine ist
unausweichlich auch wenn er noch etwas
dauert es ist genau dieser plan der
russland seit jahren verärgert ihn
aufzugeben das nennt der russische
präsident heute als bedingung für
verhandlungen mit dem westen
[Musik]
im dialog mit den usa und ihren
alliierten werden wie auf einer
vereinbarung bestehen die jede
erweiterung der nato in den osten
ausschließt genau so wie die lieferung
von waffen in unsere nachbarschaft
in riga macht der nato-generalsekretär
kurz darauf deutlich dass die allianz
eine solche bedingung nicht akzeptiert
russland hat kein vetorecht keine macht
ein einflussgebiet zu installieren indem
es seine nachbarn zu kontrollieren
versucht
und der us außenminister erklärt ohne
konkreter zu werden man habe beweise
dass russland eine invasion in die
ukraine plane am rande des nato-treffens
bereiten deutschland frankreich
großbritannien und die usa daher bereits
konkrete sanktionen vor noch ohne sie
öffentlich zu benennen
zurück nach deutschland immer noch
werden hier blindgänger aus dem zweiten
weltkrieg gefunden und entschärft in
münchen allerdings ist am mittag eine
fliegerbombe explodiert bei bauarbeiten
in der nähe des hauptbahnhofs vier
menschen wurden verletzt einer schwer
die fliegerbombe war wohl angebohrt
worden warum muss nun geklärt werden
laut bayerischem innenministerium werden
baustellen in der münchner innenstadt
eigentlich im vorfeld nach blindgängern
abgesucht
und jetzt sind wir beim sport und den
deutschen fußball frauen ja und die
haben ja gerade wirklich ein ganz ganz
tollen lauf sechste spiel in der
wm-qualifikation sechster sieg auch
gegen den gruppenzweiten portugal ließ
das dfb team nichts anbrennen drei zwei
eins stand am ende in faro ein
riesenschritt in richtung
weltmeisterschaft 2023
bundes trainerin martina voss
tecklenburg strahlt in der partie gegen
den stärksten gruppengegner beginnt ihr
team stark der schüler zeigt wieder
einmal ihre kopfballstärke nach einer
viertelstunde die führung in faro an der
algarve schülers 23 das länderspiel tor
die portugiesen entdecken nicht eng
genug laden svenja huth so eine distanz
zu sein das 2 0 nur acht minuten danach
die dfb-elf im flow das 13 0 durch
mittelfeldspielerinnen melanie leupolz
allerdings glücklich abgefälscht torfrau
merle france unterbricht dann die starke
phase zunächst ein vermeidbares foul
dann prallt der ball beim elfmeter
unglücklich an ihrem rücken die kleinen
mängel werden notiert dennoch darf die
bundestrainerin getrost planen für die
wm
deutschlands tennis profis stehen nach
14 jahren wieder in einem davis cup
halbfinale durch den sieg gegen die
favorisierten briten gestern abend in
innsbruck nach den beiden einzeln stand
es 1 1 ja und dann wieder ein starker
auftritt des deutschen doppels
tim pütz und kevin krawietz auch gegen
großbritannien haben die beiden
doppelspezialisten den entscheidenden
siegpunkt zum 2 1 geholt
bei 15 0 führung am tie break des
zweiten satzes hatten die britin sally
stories koubsky bereits fest mit dem
satzausgleich gerechnet bevor sich das
deutsche duo doch noch punkt um punkt
heran kämpfte mit dem selbstvertrauen
aus den vorangegangenen siegen gegen
serbien und dessen superstar djokovic
sowie gegen österreich nach sechs
aufeinanderfolgenden punktgewinnen
retournierte timpe 26 25 führung zum
matchgewinn und
7 zu 6 und 7 zu 6 deutschland zieht
weiter zum halbfinale nach madrid
und da heißt der gegner wieder russland
oder schweden
4 noch die lottozahlen die lauten 58 12
13 34 49 und die superzahl 7 weitere
gewinnzahlen finden sie auf lotto punkt
zdf.de und im zdf text auf seite 5 157
morgen wird weniger stürmisch aber
kälter die details hat gleich hat
johanna das heute schon mal mit
christian sievers um 22 uhr danke für
ihr interesse einen schönen abend noch
und bis machen wenn sie morgen auf
wiedersehen
[Musik]
guten abend das sturmtief daniel brachte
tatsächlich orkanböen mit auf dem
feldberg im schwarzwald aber auch auf
dem brocken im harz und auch jetzt am
abend pfeift es noch ordentlich
besonders an den küsten von nord- und
ostsee aber auch in den mittelgebirgen
an der nordsee droht sogar eine kleine
sturmflut das sturmtief daniel wird
morgen weiter nach osten abziehen und
dann wird es erst mal kälter dann geht
der regen langsam wieder in schnee über
schnee fällt aber schon heute nacht in
schleswig-holstein sonst noch etliche
schauer unterwegs dann kältesten wird
ist in schleswig holstein mit minus 1
grad sonst sinken die werte auf 4 bis 0
grad und dann diesen werten ändert sich
über tag wenig die höchsttemperaturen
liegen zwischen 2 und 6 grad morgen
vormittag schneit es in mecklenburg
vorpommern und auch hier im nördlichen
brandenburg dann gibt es einen sehr
freundlichen streifen zwischen der
lausitz und sylt richtung westen zum
beispiel im emsland gibt es allerdings
auch winter gewitter sonst sind etliche
schauer unterwegs mit schneeregen aber
auch mit schneeregen und zwischendurch
sehen sie häufig die sonne am freitag
wird es ganz anders da wird deutlich
freundlicher in süddeutschland bei
tiefen temperaturen von minus 15 grad
das zweite adventswochenende wird dann
aber schon wieder deutlich schmuddeliger
guten ab